good afternoon good afternoon Internet
we're going to try and implode this drum
today veritasium did a cool video where
you heat up some water inside you turn
it over to Steve you bung it up you cool
it down and the pressure cause it just
imploded on itself
I made a barbecue thing here earlier
sort of part of our drinking bother
doing the rest of it we're going to need
to up on there get me some water in and
then move it to here and then cool it
down and some cold water and a hose and
hopefully you'll get that illusion fact
I'm going to try and film the implosion
at two-and-a-half thousand frames a
second then a zipper looks all graceful
and crinkly are you confident about this
experiment to go work I don't think it I
reckon we're going to try I'd be
surprised the work really I'll be
surprised if we can do it with our yeah
about lack of it yeah yeah looks like
it's kicking off some right steam now
Dan it's working what I think is I think
we're ready okay yeah what to do what
Oh daddy's got this side up
go slow all right then we appear to have
suffered a partial implosion okay we did
hold your hand in wave where that's
gonna be again oh it's exploding now
have you bombed it right yeah okay Oh
God Oh
Oh oh it did it yeah we did
what happened really quickly you can see
there the water has even started
movement let's see how quickly the water
sat on top yeah but you just got whipped
out from under it yeah that's mental
it's really cool experiment okay
that was really impressive actually it
was actually a very consistent
experiment we um I don't think we left
at cooking long enough the first time we
tried it so we got like a partial yeah
it sort of fluid on the sides here from
a bit and then in the end it had to cook
the bench here so it formed in yeah and
then it gunked yeah so the plum gunk
type thing yeah good work but we got the
gunk in slow-mo
yeah so it's good good we might revisit
this one day maybe just try and be
better at it you know just try a bit
better scientists and in the meantime
follow us on Twitter subscribe to the
slimmer guys and just watch a bunch of
slow-mo videos on YouTube we make a lot
of sale latex a la to them as you can
see there dan and I learned a lot about
pressure and on the subject of learning
things a lot of people are going back to
school this week or already have them at
school but it's very important to
remember that around the world in
underprivileged areas a lot of people
are no mat school so we're all asking
for you to donate to comic relief to
help the kids in underprivileged areas
try and get a decent education so if you
can please donate comic relief using the
link on the screen any amount helps the
greater goal Thanks